sondervermögen für die bundeswehr aber
herr von palo haushaltsberatungen dürfen
doch sicherlich auch eine rolle gespielt
haben bei den pressekonferenzen
ja so ist es denn in dieser woche ist
haushaltswoche der haushalt wird
verabschiedet
2022 etwas spät im jahr das ist aber
immer so nach einer bundestagswahl und
deswegen sind wir hier heute auf der
fraktionsebene am montag sie kennen das
sonst vom dienstag aber in einer
haushaltswoche da wird der haushalt ja
ab morgen die verschiedenen ressorts
kommen da zu wort gelesen und am freitag
dann die endgültige abstimmung über den
haushalt 20 22
495 7 9 milliarden ausgaben
138,9 4 milliarden lautet die
neuverschuldung und dann kommen noch
einmal hundert milliarden dazu das
sogenannte sondervermögen der bundeswehr
der halle haben sich die ampel
fraktionen und die cdu csu gestern
geeinigt man will nämlich das ganze
durch eine grundgesetzänderung
außerhalb quasi dieses haushaltes
platzieren damit die schuldenbremse
wieder eingehalten werden kann ab dem
kommenden jahr alles etwas kompliziert
jedenfalls brauchte man die zustimmung
auch der größten oppositionsfraktion der
cdu/csu und da gab es ein zähes ringen
um diese 100 milliarden die der
bundeskanzler jahr bei seiner
historischen zeitenwende rede hier im
deutschen bundestag am 27
februar angekündigt hatte und gerade die
linken sowohl der bei der spd wie auch
bei den bündnisgrünen waren alles andere
erfreut seit damals und man hat heftig
gekämpft
damit das alles auch in trockene tücher
kommt vier fraktionen gemeinsam hinter
so einen beschluss zu bringen bedarf es
ein oder anderen kompromisses das ist
also gestern gelungen in einer kleinen
arbeitsgruppe jetzt wird das in den
fraktionen beraten die alle noch sitzen
in einer haushaltswoche am montag gibt
es ja zunächst die partei
pressekonferenzen dann kommen die
fraktionen zusammen deswegen das ganze
geht hier alles etwas mehr in den abend
hinein und da erwartet man vor allen
dingen bei den grünen und auch bei der
spd durchaus
die ein oder andere diskussion
und die fraktionschefs haben sich wie
immer hier vor ihren fraktionssitzungen
geäußert und wir wollen mal anfangen mit
der größten fraktion mit der spd rolf
mützenich jahre lang hier schon im
parlament als außenpolitiker tätig er
gehört zum linken flügel seiner fraktion
und auch gerade er hat sich besonders
schwer getan auch mit diesem prozess
aufrüstung der bundeswehr soll so nicht
genannt werden und er hat heute morgen
noch mal in einem interview gesagt in
einem radiointerview dass also diese
abstruse kennziffer von zwei prozent zum
glück nicht ins grundgesetz aufgenommen
werden musste das hatte die union ja am
anfang verlangt ist dann davon abgerückt
also zwei prozent neben den 100
milliarden wird es die ersten vier jahre
geben man hat ein zeitfenster von fünf
jahren genommen und gesagt nicht jedes
jahr zwei prozent sondern eben im mittel
sozusagen zwei prozent je nachdem welche
rüstungsvorhaben wie viel kosten und
danach will man dann mal weitersehen
rolf mützenich jedenfalls fing hier
heute sein statement zunächst mit der
eigentlichen tatsache an dass wir
natürlich haushaltswoche haben und was
da alles schönes beschlossen werden kann
[Musik]
gießen werden in der bereinigungssitzung
des haushaltsausschusses erst noch mal
so ich will den fachpolitikern von der
kmk auch toll ich kann morgen welche
schwer
umsetzen wollen das ist natürlich
insbesondere für uns sozialdemokraten
und zu einem garten im bereich der
arbeits und arbeitsmarktpolitik der
sozialpolitik aber eben auch dass uns ja
ein wohnungsbau sowie nochmal insgesamt
um 8 milliarden auf der strecke auch
anwachsen werden ich finde das sind
wichtige anhaltspunkte auch die noch mal
die entlastungs pakete die wir auf den
weg bringen unterstreichen zum anderen
wenn wir diese woche auf die
rentenanpassung beschließen und dann
natürlich auch noch mal ganz wichtig
weil wir damit auch ein großes
wahlversprechen von seiten der spd
füllen die anhebung des mindestlohns auf
12 euro also diese haushaltswoche alles
in sich mit diesen auch erhöhungen für
rentnerinnen und rentner daten auch für
6 millionen
unmittelbar oder indirekt auch von links
präsentieren zum anderen gehe ich zu
zeigen noch davon aus dass dieser
sitzungsort version davon öl beschließen
werden sondern sind über 100 milliarden
euro aus können sich für die bundeswehr
insbesondere ausstattung so laden aber
auch die schaffung von gerätschaften
gelang gestern uns in addition aber auch
mit meiner position als auch
verständlich
grundgesetzänderung findet er verpasst
immerhin weg zu bringen diese
sondervermögen ist ein ohr investiver
anteil wird aber nichts die
zukunftsausgaben den wir uns im
koalitionsvertrag
vorgenommen haben in irgendeiner form in
den nächsten jahren belasten auf das ist
eine wichtige feststellung ich bin
dankbar auch gegenüber der cdu/csu dass
die touristen weg nach durchaus
herausforderungen verhandlungen mit uns
auch gehen wird insbesondere die frage
dass nur so viele akteure zur verfügung
stellen will wie von seiten neben
koalitionsfraktion für die zwei linken
mehr in ungarn keinen zweiten wir hier
im bundestag nicht gegeben werden kann
offensichtlich ist das optisch bin auf
das sogenannte zwei prozent ziel was
sich die verteidigungsminister 2014
gegeben haben nicht ein verfassungsrang
erhalten wird das erste zukünftige
generationen aber auch aus als
gesetzgeber aus meiner sicht zu stark
gebunden und dass wir eben auch im
bereich des wirtschaftsplans und der
zwischen grund wurde in der vereinbarung
wichtige ziele erreicht das ist
sozusagen für woche
völlig märz hat gerade gesagt
erwartet dass geschlossen abgestimmt
wird seitens der ampel wie robust sage
ich mal werden sie den abgeordneten in
der in ihrer fraktion gegenüber treten
die angeben mit nein zu stimmen und
sagen sie ruhig mal haben sie da schon
anzeigen wie viel das sein werden die
nicht mit ja stimmen werden dass er der
erste komplex der zweite komplex ist
christian lindner hat mit bezug auf die
vorschläge von hubertus heil gesagt
erwartet
gegenfinanzierungsvorschläge werden sie
den hubertus heil drängen diese auch
vorzulegen um seinen vorschlag dann
tatsächlich mehrheitsfähig in der
koalition zu machen
die unruhen sondern sie im und csu eine
verabredung getroffen hat für das
sondervermögen und wir werden natürlich
dort auch gemeinsam im deutschen
bundestag auftreten ich bin ein
fraktionsvorsitzender die nicht minder
märz noch angedeutet hatte vor einigen
wochen
abgeordnete zu irgendeiner abstimmung
oder nicht abstimmung zu zwingen will
erneute in der fraktion über die
sondervermögen bzw über das richtungs
gesetz sprechen dann werden mit
sicherheit auch abgeordnete sind das
wort nehmen ihnen auch zusätzliche
fragen haben und ich hoffe dass durch
die antworten auf den zusätzlichen
fragen wie auch zu einem weitgehenden
abstimmungsverhalten von seiten der spd
fraktion kommen zum zweiten
aspekt finde ich es
das schon irritieren der finanzminister
hat einen klaren auftrag aus dem
koalitionsausschuss in der
vorvergangenen
vorvergangenen koalitionsausschuss
mitgenommen was das
vermögen was die fragen des klima geldes
bzw der entlastung auch der bürgerinnen
und bürger betrifft und wir werden uns
gegenseitig informieren wie wir
insbesondere auch noch zu zusätzlichen
entlastungen kommen werden wenn wir dann
wissen ob die jetzigen entlastungen die
wir ja auf den weg gebracht haben nicht
reichen
nützlich sie haben heute morgen im
deutschlandfunk die zwei prozent als
abstruse
kennzeichnen den bundeskanzler richter
zeitenwenden rede auf diese abstruse
kennziffer gekommen natürlich das
aufgegriffen was 2014 die
verteidigungsminister in ihrer eigenen
verantwortung und außenminister damals
in ihrer eigenen verantwortung
beschlossen beschlossen haben und der
haushaltsgesetzgeber ist jedes jahr frei
den
verteidigungshaushalt anzupassen wir
haben in massiv in den letzten jahren
erhöht wir haben uns nie an dieser
kennziffer orientiert sondern wir wollen
fähigkeitslücken schließen
fähigkeitslücken inhalt der bundeswehr
wir wollen zu einem besseren
beschaffungswesen kommen und kennziffern
deuten ja eben auch an dass sie keine
aussagekraft haben wenn sie sich zum
beispiel anschauen ein länder mit einem
geringen bruttoinlandsprodukt die reißen
dass zwei prozent ziel ganz leicht und
auf der anderen seite starke
wirtschaftliche länder wie wir sind eben
unter dem zwei prozent ziel geblieben
obwohl wir 50 milliarden euro jedes jahr
für die bundeswehr zur verfügung
gestellt haben deswegen finde ich schon
müssen wir uns immer wieder vor augen
führen dass das der bundeswehr nicht
hilft sondern nur ganz konkrete
investitionen die die bundeswehr auch
erreichen und deswegen habe ich eben
auch dass zu der kennziffer gesagt als
jemand der
haushaltsgesetzgeber ist und hier im
parlament und die damalige vereinbarung
in wales eben nicht unterschrieben hat
urlaub soll sich dann auf diese
kennziffer festgelegt wenn die gar keine
aussagekraft hat nun er hat sich auf
diese kennziffer festgelegt weil wir sie
durch das sondervermögen in den nächsten
jahren erreichen werden wir werden ja 50
milliarden zum beispiel für den
verteidigungshaushalt haben 100
milliarden die auf der strecke in den
nächsten fünf jahren für die beschaffung
von großen investitionen erreicht werden
nun möglicherweise werden wir dann auch
sogar manchmal über das zwei prozent
ziel gehen das weiß auch olaf scholz
deswegen hat er sich nicht auf zwei
prozent bezogen sondern hat von dem nato
ziel gesprochen aber das nato ziel sind
auch insbesondere fähigkeitslücken die
die nato hat oder synergieeffekte sie
wissen besser als ich die nato gibt 800
milliarden euro im jahr für militär und
rüstung aus und ich finde diese 800
milliarden euro könnten besser
zusammengeführt werden dann würden wir
uns von solchen kennziffern mit
sicherheit schnell wieder lösen
nicht die fähigkeit haben sie gerade
angesprochen die sollen später
entscheidend seien nicht mehr die zwei
prozent das könnte natürlich aber auch
bedeuten dass deutschland plötzlich drei
fregatten anschaffen muss weil sie die
fähigkeit nicht haben das waren dann
weit über das zwei prozent ziel hinaus
kommt und es gibt jede vorstellung und
jeden wunsch der punkt wird mit
sicherheit sein dass wir uns dann klug
beraten insbesondere mit den partnern
welche länder für bestimmte
teilstreitkräfte besondere fähigkeiten
zur verfügung stellen deutschland kann
das tun aber auch die niederlande oder
italien
und ich finde da kommt es eben auf die
kreativität auch des nato
generalsekretärs und letztlich auch der
nato-verteidigungsminister an endlich
auch zu diesem zu dieser engeren
zusammenarbeit zu kommen die man eben
auch sich in wels versprochen hat und
über welt redet man leider eben nur im
zusammenhang mit einem eben prozent ziel
und nicht über die frage wie kann man
die qualität letztlich auch einer
sicherheitspolitik die ja für europa
auch eine klammer sein soll besser auf
den weg bringen das 2 prozent ziehen
will 2014 unterschrieben von der nato
von den außenministern und damals war
frank walter steinmeier der spd mann der
deutsche außenminister der das
unterschrieben hat und seit diesem jahr
an haderten die sozialdemokraten mit
dieser frage zwei prozent ziel und jetzt
hat man sich geeinigt das könnte ja
eventuell sogar noch schlimmer kommen je
nach fähigkeiten die man aufstellen muss
für die nato zum beispiel muss man von
den 100 milliarden gleich mal 20
milliarden nehmen um munition an zu
schaffen sondern es ist man gar nicht in
der lage die nato verpflichtungen zu
erfüllen also da liegt einiges im argen
bei der bundeswehr für die ampel
fraktionen war sehr unterschiedlich was
ihnen wichtig war der fdp war natürlich
sehr wichtig dass die schuldenbremse ab
nächstem jahr wieder greift und es war
auch eine idee des
bundesfinanzministers und fdp
vorsitzenden christian lindner ein
sondervermögen zu schaffen klammer auf
eigentlich 100 milliarden schulden für
die bundeswehr außerhalb dieser
schuldenbremse zu platzieren und
christian dürre der fraktionschef zeigte
sich vor der fraktionssitzung der fdp
sehr zufrieden mit dem gefundenen
kompromiss von gestern
wir haben in den letzten wochen ja schon
oft über waffenlieferungen gesprochen
ich habe jetzt vernommen dass auf
europäischer ebene insbesondere an öl
embargo man eine einigung näher getreten
ist und das freut mich natürlich dass
hier der westen und insbesondere die
europäische union mit einer stimme
spricht in dem zusammenhang will ich
einen wichtigen punkt erwähnen den wir
hier in deutschland tun können und das
haben sie vernommen in der vergangenen
nacht hat es hier einen durchbruch
gegeben beim thema sondervermögen für
die bundeswehr denn dieser angriffskrieg
russlands hat uns einmal mehr gezeigt
wie wichtig es ist dass wir unsere
eigene truppe die bundeswehr
bündnisfähig halten und
verteidigungsfähigkeit besondere und die
oft beschriebene wende die zeitenwende
die wird hier an dieser stelle ganz
konkret mit leben erfüllt es geht um 100
milliarden euro für die bundeswehr und
ich betone für die bundeswehr das war
uns als fdp besonders wichtig dass
dieses geld für die ausstattung der
truppe in den kommenden jahren zur
verfügung steht die soldatinnen und
soldaten haben auch diese anerkennung
verdient das entsprechend die bundeswehr
so ausgestattet ist dass sie ihren
aufgaben gerecht wird wir schaffen ist
damit in den kommenden jahren anders als
die vorgängerregierung
das zwei prozent ziel was wir uns gegen
bei der nahezu dem wir uns gegenüber der
nato verpflichtet haben zu erfüllen auch
das ist ein wichtiger schritt nach vorne
nachdem also die bundeswehr in den
kommenden in den letzten jahren das muss
man so deutlich sagen vernachlässigt
worden ist werden wir in den kommenden
jahren hier ein sehr starkes signal
setzen können und als fdp-fraktion war
uns insbesondere wichtig dass es eine
änderung des grundgesetzes gibt deswegen
braucht es ja auch die zwei drittel
mehrheit im deutschen bundestag insofern
ist es gut dass es in der gestrigen
nacht eine einigung mit cdu und csu in
dieser frage gegeben hat um auch die
ganz konkrete verwendung der mittel
sicherzustellen und dass es eben keine
aufweichung der schuldenbremse an dieser
stelle gibt sondern dass wir im
grundgesetz mit zweidrittelmehrheit
entsprechend das sondervermögen
verankern aus sicht der fdp sind also
zwei wichtige ziele erreicht worden als
erstes wir stärken ganz konkret die
bundeswehr unsere soldatinnen und
soldaten
mit einem beispiellosen programm von 100
milliarden euro und das zweite ist wir
werden das sondervermögen im grundgesetz
verankern weder die schuldenbremse
aufweichen noch die steuern erhöhen und
das ist natürlich ausdrücklich auch ein
erfolg von christian lindner als fdp
finanzminister der ja diese verhandlung
maßgeblich geführt hat der zweite punkt
den ich ansprechen möchte betrifft auch
diese sitzungswoche es nicht eine
haushalts sitzungswoche für den
bundeshaushalt
2022 den wir in zweiter und dritter
lesung dann am freitag verabschieden
werden und unsere ziele stehen natürlich
auch im zeichen der aktuellen lage wir
wollen die wirtschaftliche stabilität
deutschlands sichern die
handlungsfähigkeit sicherstellen und
gleichzeitig zukunftsinvestitionen
insbesondere in bildung in die
digitalisierung und die co2 neutralität
stärken wir wollen die wirtschaft
fördern indem wir gute rahmenbedingungen
setzen und deswegen ist dieser haushalt
auch im zeichen des aktuellen krieges in
der ukraine denn ich habe immer gesagt
die geopolitische stärke deutschlands
ist insbesondere seine wirtschaftliche
stärke und mit an ergänzungs haushalt
von 40 milliarden euro volumen leisten
wir unseren beitrag
für die humanitäre hilfe für geflüchtete
menschen wie entlasten die bürgerinnen
und bürger ich komme darauf gleich noch
einmal zu sprechen und wir federn ab das
was die unternehmen zurzeit auch an
mehrbelastung aufgrund dieser krise
haben insbesondere in bezug auf die
gestiegenen energiepreise
für die weitere finanzplanung steht für
uns als fdp fraktion eines sehr klar
fest wir verdanken eben unsere
wirtschaftliche stärke und am ende des
tages unsere gute haushaltssituation in
den vergangenen jahren der
schuldenbremse und diese
handlungsfähigkeit gerade in der krise
die deutschland jetzt nach der pandemie
auch während dieses furchtbaren krieges
noch einmal unter beweis stellt diese
handlungsfähigkeit wollen wir auch in
zukunft erhalten und deswegen halten wir
natürlich daran fest ab dem jahr 2023 so
hat es sich die ampelkoalition in den
koalitionsvertrag geschrieben ab dem
jahr 2023 zur schuldenbremse
zurückzukehren die schuldenbremse das
wissen sie ist das markenzeichen der fdp
und insofern ist dieser bundeshaushalt
das und re vorankommenden bundeshaushalt
der bereits nach der sommerpause ab
september im deutschen bundestag beraten
werden wird zur schuldenbremse
zurückzukehren der dritte punkt den ich
ansprechen möchte ist das thema
entlastung in dieser woche gehen zwei
wichtige entlastungsmaßnahmen sozusagen
online könnte man sagen das eine ist
dass neun euro ticket das ist schon
online verfügbar und das zweite ist zum
ersten juni der tank rabatt wir
unterstützen damit insbesondere
arbeitnehmerinnen arbeitnehmer die auf
das auto angewiesen sind und aufgrund
der gestiegenen benzin- und dieselpreise
sich eben gestiegenen kosten gegenüber
sehen klar ist auch wir hätten uns hier
noch ein anderes modell technisch
vorstellen können aber dass es kein
geheimnis auf der einen seite auf der
anderen seite haben wir uns eben auf die
energie steuersenkung für benzin und
diesel innerhalb der koalition geeinigt
und umso wichtiger ist jetzt dass diese
entlastung auch bei den autofahrern und
autofahrern ankommt ich sehe hier
insbesondere den
bundeswirtschaftsminister und sein haus
in der pflicht ich bin sicher dass
minister habeck bereits daran gearbeitet
dass die entlastung an der zapfsäule
tatsächlich bei den menschen bei den
autofahrern auch ankommt ich habe eine
ganz grundsätzliche frage putins
angriffskrieg offenbart ja ganz
eindeutig die schwäche und schlechte
aufstellung der bundeswehr das ist
eigentlich eine notlage der bundeswehr
warum gehen sie diese konstruktion mit
dem sondervermögen wirklichkeit sind das
100 milliarden schulden die aufgenommen
werden außerhalb der schuldenbremse
dafür ist doch extra die auflösung der
schuldenbremse da wenn eine notlage im
staat existiert dann gibt es eben die
schuldenbremse für die jahre nicht die
schuldenbremse es darauf angelegt am
konkreten haushaltsjahr schulden
aufzunehmen um die ausnahme situation
sozusagen zu beseitigen das war
beispielsweise während der korona
pandemie der fall auch dieser haushalt
steht ja noch im zeichen der
wirtschaftskrise im zusammenhang mit der
korona pandemie aber da müssen sie
haushalterisch das tun ganz konkret und
diese situation zu beseitigen beim
sondervermögen wollen wir uns ja bewusst
nicht auf ein jahr beschränkt sondern
beim sondervermögen geht es darum in den
kommenden jahren rüstungsprojekte
ausstattungs projekte für die
soldatinnen und soldaten zu finanzieren
also das ist eine andere situation
deswegen halte ich es besser dass über
das grundgesetz mit einer
grundgesetzänderung zu machen damit
dieses geld zweckgebunden der bundeswehr
zur verfügung steht nicht zur
beseitigung der allgemeinen
wirtschaftlichen situation der
haushaltsnotlage also die argumentation
des grundgesetzes die ich ausdrücklich
teile ist übrigens noch einmal bestätigt
worden vom verfassungsgerichtshof in
hessen bei dem urteil über den
landeshaushalt der schwarz grünen
landesregierung dort der ist ja kassiert
worden vom verfassungsgericht und da hat
man gesagt das was der
haushaltsgesetzgeber tun muss muss
darauf ausgerichtet sein die
haushaltsnotlage zu beseitigen hier
haben wir bei der bundeswehr aber keine
haushaltsnotlage sondern wir haben man
muss es so deutlich sagen politisches
versagen der vergangenheit und dafür ist
die schuldenbremse nicht geeignet
sondern ist das sondervermögen das
richtige instrument aus meiner sicht
ja dann hat das christian dürner noch
einmal klargestellt es hat lange
gedauert bis sich die ampel fraktionen
mit der union geeinigt haben das liegt
auch an den vorstellungen der union und
der grünen die weit auseinander lagen
nämlich die cyber abwehrstrategie
wollten die grünen gerne von diesen 100
milliarden finanzieren die ist unter
anderem ja nicht im
bundesfinanzministerium angelegt und die
union hat argumentiert diese 100
milliarden müssen für komplett für die
bundeswehr verwendet werden für die
persönliche ausrüstung für neue
beschaffungsmaßnahmen und die cyber
abwehrstrategie die soll aus dem
laufenden haushalt beschlossen werden
die grünen lange dagegen gehalten
gestern abend haben sie dann nachgegeben
obwohl es da noch ein paar unklarheiten
gibt ob die grünen delegation
tatsächlich zugestimmt hat den annalena
baerbock hat den raum verlassen um mit
den iren zu reden und dann ist durch ein
missgeschick nach einer halben stunde 40
minuten wurde dann verkündet dass man
sich geeinigt hatte da hatten die grünen
eigentlich noch gar nicht ihr plazet
gegeben aber sei es drum heute morgen
waren sie der meinung das ist ein guter
kompromiss und dieser meinung ist auch
die fraktionschefin katharina dröge die
ihr statement damit anfängt
es ist gut dass wir gestern abend zu
einer einigung für das sondervermögen
bundeswehr gekommen sind angesichts der
schwierigen sicherheitspolitischen
situation in der wir uns gerade in
europa befinden wäre ein scheitern keine
option gewesen für uns grüne waren in
den verhandlungen drei punkte wichtig
erstens braucht es aus unserer sicht
dringend eine bessere ausrüstung der
bundeswehr
über 16 jahre lang hat die union die
ausrüstung der bundeswehr vor die wand
gefahren
dass es insbesondere jetzt in dieser
zeit zu einem problem geworden
zweitens war es uns wichtig dass in der
grundgesetzänderung ein klarer bezug zur
stärkung der bündnisfähigkeit vorkommt
in diesen zeiten ausgerechnet die
bündnisfähigkeit aus der
grundgesetzänderung streichen zu wollen
so wie es die union vorgehabt hat wäre
ein fatales signal an unsere
partnerinnen und partner in europa
gewesen und drittens haben wir grünen
dafür geworben eine sicherheitspolitik
auf höhe der zeit zu machen das heißt
auch sich besser zu wappnen gegen
cyberangriffe das heißt auch sicherheit
vernetzt international zu denken und
damit unsere partner zu ertüchtigen
dies haben wir jetzt in richtung das
gesetz abgesichert natürlich ist das
ganze ein kompromiss wenn vier
fraktionen miteinander verhandeln müssen
sich am ende
bewegen aus unserer sicht ist es gut
dass die union zustimmen konnte dass wir
mehr investitionen für die bundeswehr im
rahmen eine erhöhung der
nettokreditaufnahme
finanzieren das heißt wir erhöhen die
neuverschuldung um 100 milliarden euro
außerhalb des anwendungsbereichs der
schuldenbremse damit bleiben spielräume
im bundeshaushalt für wichtige andere
projekte es ist außerdem gut dass wir
uns darauf verständigen konnten dass das
zwei prozent ziel nicht im grundgesetz
verankert wird aus unserer sicht sollte
man die ausrüstung der bundeswehr an der
sache orientieren an dem was notwendig
ist nicht an symbolen wir haben jetzt
vereinbart dass wir wahrscheinlich in
den nächsten fünf jahren ein
entsprechendes ziel erreichen werden
dass wir uns danach aber strukturell an
dem orientieren was notwendig ist
nämlich dehnfähigkeit zielen die wir
auch im rahmen der nato vereinbart haben
und drittens war es uns natürlich
wichtig dass cyber sicherheit und auch
die ertüchtigung von partnerinnen und
partnern aus dem sondervermögen
finanziert werden hierzu war die union
nicht bereit sie hätte hier an eine
einigung scheitern lassen das war aus
unserer sicht nicht an der sache
orientiert aber in einer zeit in der die
sicherheit in europa so herausgefordert
ist wie jetzt wird es für uns keine
option gewesen daran eine einigung
scheitern zu lassen und deswegen haben
wir gemeinsam als ampel fraktionen einen
anderen weg gefunden die notwendigen
investitionen abzusichern
das zweite was uns in dieser woche
beschäftigt sind die haushaltsberatungen
deutschen bundestag belegen als ampel
fraktionen unserem ersten gemeinsamen
haushalt vor der auf mehrere krisen
gleichzeitig reagieren muss auf die
klimakrise die korona pandemie und den
krieg in der ukraine
hier haben wir gemeinsam klare akzente
gesetzt so verdoppeln wir beispielsweise
die investitionen in den klimaschutz im
vergleich zur vorgängerregierung
wir unterstützen die kommunen bei der
aufnahme von geflüchteten aus der
ukraine in höhe von zwei milliarden euro
und wir stärken den sozialen wohnungsbau
deutlich und wir haben uns jetzt schon
auf entlastungs paket in höhe von 30
milliarden euro verstehen nicht um die
bürgerinnen und bürger angesichts der
steigenden fossilen preise zu entlasten
und wir werden auch mit blick auf
weitere preissteigerungen handlungsfähig
bleiben müssen als ampelkoalition
deswegen ist es so wichtig dass der
finanzminister wie vereinbart jetzt
schnell zu einem aus zahlungssystem für
das klima geld kommt dass er hier erste
schritte vorlegt dass es einfacher
unbürokratischer und gerechter weg die
ganze finanzierung für cybersicherheit
et cetera wir jetzt nicht aus dem
sondervermögen gestemmt was wurde ihnen
dann dazu gesichert in welcher höhe das
außerhalb des sondervermögens passieren
soll also was gibt es da für konkrete
zusagen also wir miteinander vereinbart
als koalitionsfraktionen dass die
innenministerin gemeinsam mit den
anderen ressorts eine strategie vorlegen
muss zur stärkung der cyber sicherheit
da ist sie noch nicht so weit das muss
sie über den sommer tun das wird mit
sicherheit ein zweistelliger
milliardenbetrag sein zusätzlich zu den
ausgaben für die ertüchtigung von
partnern die im bereich eines
einstelligen milliardenbetrags sein
werden grün hatten wir zunächst waren ja
zunächst total überrumpelt die fraktion
von diesem ganzen sondervermögen dann
haben sie ein erweitertes
sicherheitskonzept
angekündigt nichts davon ist jetzt übrig
geblieben das geld geht ausschließlich
an die bundeswehr wie erklären sie sich
diese niederlage wir haben von anfang an
gesagt dass wir für einen breiteren
sicherheitsbegriff werben wir haben nie
gesagt dass wir alle mittel die dafür
notwendig sind aus dem sondervermögen
finanzieren werden auf der einen seite
haben wir gesagt es braucht mehr
investitionen im bereich energie
souveränität hier gibt es bereits ein
sondervermögen im bundeshaushalt dass
wir noch einmal mit mehr mitteln
ausgestattet haben dass wir den einen
teil über den wir gesprochen haben ein
zweiter ist das thema zivile
krisenprävention humanitäre hilfe hier
hat das auswärtige amt den höchsten
jemals vorzuweisen das haben wir im
rahmen der haushaltsverhandlungen
durchgesetzt und das dritte waren die
ausgaben im rahmen des sondervermögens
hier haben wir gesagt wollen mit drei
bereiche finanzieren wir haben uns jetzt
auf den kompromiss eingelassen zu sagen
das sondervermögen verwenden wir für die
bundeswehr die anderen im bereich cyber
und ertüchtigung von partnern werden
aber ebenfalls aus dem bundeshaushalt
finanziert das heißt die mittel werden
zur verfügung gestellt das muss der
finanzminister jetzt tun
die drei ampel fraktionen sind also
zufrieden mit dem gestern gefundenen
kompromiss mit der cdu csu sie brauchen
die cdu csu für eine änderung des
grundgesetzes eine zweidrittelmehrheit
in der dann das sondervermögen spricht
die schulden für die bundeswehr
niedergeschrieben werden sowohl hier im
bundestag wie auch im bundesrat jetzt
wegen musste man mit der cdu/csu auch
verhandeln dass das so lange gedauert
hat das ist ein bisschen befremdlich
denn die rede von olaf scholz stammt vom
27 februar jetzt drei monate später also
der beschluss und hier im bundestag ist
man guter hoffnung dass das ganze noch
diese oder nächste woche dann durch den
bundestag und den bundesrat gebracht
werden kann die cdu csu jedenfalls sieht
sich bestätigt sie hat forderungen
aufgestellt 100 milliarden nur für die
bundeswehr und hat sich dort auf ganzer
linie durchgesetzt das meint zumindest
friedrich merz der fraktionsvorsitzende
der cdu/csu das ist ein guter tag für
die bundeswehr und es ist ein guter tag
für die sicherheits und
verteidigungsfähigkeit der
bundesrepublik deutschland ich will ganz
herzlich danken alexander dobrindt
mathias middelberg und so wadephul die
in den letzten wochen die verhandlungen
mit der koalition um den vorschlag des
bundeskanzlers geführt haben ein
sondervermögen in höhe von 100
milliarden euro zu errichten für die
bundeswehr und die diese verhandlungen
in der letzten nacht erfolgreich
abschließen konnten wir haben der
bundesregierung in aussicht gestellt dem
vorschlag des bundeskanzlers zuzustimmen
wir haben in der haushaltsdebatte vor
einigen wochen sechs punkte genannt
unter deren erfüllung wir bereit wären
dem programm zuzustimmen und ich kann
heute feststellen die koalition aus spd
grünen und fdp
ist dankenswerterweise bereit gewesen
und in allen diesen sechs punkten zu
folgen das ist ein großer erfolg für die
parteiübergreifende zusammenarbeit im
deutschen bundestag das zeigt dass
regierung und opposition gemeinsam etwas
auf den weg bringen können und das zeigt
auch dass wir es ernst meinen wenn wir
sagen dass wir eine verantwortungsvolle
und konstruktive opposition im deutschen
bundestag sein wollen wenn es um so
wichtige fragen geht dann muss taktik
und polit- und parteitaktik zurückstehen
dann steht im vordergrund die politische
mögliche einigung diese einigung ist
möglich geworden und wir können jetzt
den gesetzgebungsprozess
auf die zielgerade bringen dh zweite
dritte lesung das bereits eingebrachten
gesetzentwurfs der bundesregierung
werden in den nächsten tagen und wochen
anstehen wichtig ist dass wir das
ergebnis festhalten es werden 100
milliarden euro eines sondervermögens
ausschließlich für die streitkräfte zur
verfügung gestellt werden es wird einen
wirtschaftsplan geben der auch die
entsprechenden beschaffungsvorhaben
auflistet der haushaltsausschuss wird in
einem eigenständigen gremium die
ausgaben überwachen es wird einen
tilgungsplan geben und es wird auch im
errichtungs gesetz eine entsprechende
verpflichtung der bundesrepublik
deutschland eingegangen werden über
diese 100 milliarden euro hinaus auf
dauer die verpflichtungen zu erfüllen
die innerhalb der nato vereinbart werden
das heißt wir werden auch dass zwei
prozent ziel oder mehr in den jahren
nach der erschöpfung dieses
sondervermögens bereitstellen aus dem
bundeshaushalt um die bündnisse und
verteidigungsfähigkeit der
bundesrepublik deutschland und ihrer
verbündeten zu gewährleisten noch einmal
das ist ein wirklich guter tag für die
bundeswehr und ich will es noch mal
sagen ganz herzlichen dank für die
wirklich sehr sehr gute konstruktive
aber auch sehr zielstrebige verhandlung
die unsere drei kolleginnen da geführt
haben das ist ein wirklich guter tag ich
hoffe im übrigen dass die
koalitionsfraktionen spd grüne und fdp
dies hier genauso
hätten und wenn das der fall sein sollte
dann können wir hier sehr schnell zur
entscheidung kommen
es ist ein großer erfolg dass cdu csu
und die ampel fraktionen die
regierungsparteien sich gestern darauf
verständigt
haben das paket mit 100 milliarden für
die bundeswehr und das erreichen des
zwei prozent ziels zu schnüren
es war klar dass so ein ergebnis nur
dann erzielt werden kann um eine
grundgesetzänderung zu ermöglichen
wenn es gemeinsam mit der cdu csu im
deutschen bundestag geht wir haben von
anfang an der ampel signalisiert dass
wir konstruktiv bereit sind diese
entscheidung mitzutragen in einer
breiten basis in der mitte des deutschen
bundestages im parlament aber das geht
auch nur dann wenn die ankündigungen des
bundeskanzlers erfüllt sind und nicht
durch wünsche aus den ampel fraktionen
aufgeweicht werden es gab in den letzten
tagen und wochen
vielfältigste vorschläge und ideen von
seiten der spd und auch den grünen wie
man teile dieser 100 milliarden anders
verwenden kann als für die bundeswehr
und wir haben immer sehr deutlich gesagt
dass eine einigung mit uns dann möglich
ist wenn diese 100 milliarden
ausschließlich für unsere streitkräfte
für die bundeswehr zur verfügung stehen
und nicht für andere maßnahmen verwendet
werden andere maßnahmen können auch
sinnvoll sein da wir uns da nicht falsch
verstehen aber dann müssen sie aus dem
regulären haushalt
finanziert werden können nicht über ein
sondervermögen was immer sonder schulden
bedeutet eine finanzierung bekommen die
am blatt gestern eingesehen dass das der
weg ist den man gemeinsam gehen kann ich
bin dankbar dass spd und grüne ihre
anderen vorschläge dieses geld zu
verwenden aufgegeben haben und damit war
dann auch der weg frei auf eine
verständigung an dieser stelle natürlich
bedeutet das dass mit diesen 100 mio die
bundeswehr
aufgerüstet wird sie wird ausgerüstet
und aufgerüstet dh mit modernsten waffen
systemen ausgestattet dazu gehört auch
die sicherstellung der nuklearen
teilhabe
das heißt die sicherstellung des
deutschen beitrags an der atomaren
abschreckung auch das ist teil dessen
was mit diesen 100 milliarden erreicht
werden wird wir erwarten übrigens dass
die nato ziele die auch ja in den
nächsten jahren neu gefasst werden nicht
sinken sondern steigen werden das heißt
unsere beiträge an den
bündnisverpflichtungen werden ihr höher
als niedriger und deswegen war es so
wichtig nicht nur über die 100
milliarden jetzt eine vereinbarung zu
bekommen sondern auch langfristig
darüber zu diskutieren wie werden diese
finanziellen beiträge aus deutschland
sichergestellt auch dass es gelungen
eine vereinbarung darüber zu treffen
dass auch nach der verwendung der 100
milliarden euro der haushalt weiter in
der lage sein muss unsere nato
verpflichtungen die dann zu künftigen
nato ziele auch zu finanzieren von
deswegen ja es ist gut und es ist schön
dass es gelungen ist in einer
gemeinsamen verantwortung zwischen den
ampel fraktionen unter cdu und csu diese
entscheidung zu treffen wir gehen davon
aus dass das jetzt auch schnell
parlamentarisch umgesetzt werden kann
aus unserer sicht ist es auch möglich
dass bereits in dieser woche zu tun das
hängt jetzt an der ampel ob man die
entscheidung im parlament noch diese
woche oder im der darauffolgende
sitzungswoche umsetzen will dankeschön
alexander dobrindt war dass der
csu-landesgruppenchef und erste
stellvertreter von friedrich merz er
selber hat die verhandlungen für die
union geführt und ist hochzufrieden die
cdu/csu hat ihr ziel erreicht sie wird
gebraucht zur mehrheitsbildung logisch
bei einer zwei drittel mehr darüber
verfügt die ampeln nicht und man hat
sich von seiten der union in vielen
punkten durchgesetzt insgesamt kann man
strich drunter machen und sagen vier
fraktionen sind hoch zufrieden mit dem
kompromiss wenn der ein oder andere in
der fraktion den verschiedenen
fraktionen vielleicht auch sich was
anderes erwartet hatte wird das
jedenfalls sicherlich hier eine breite
mehrheit finden wann und wie es dann zur
abstimmung kommt das werden wir sehen
alexander dobrindt hat es gerade selber
angedeutet es könnte sich auch auf die
nächste woche gelaufen allerdings sitzt
der bundesrat in 14 tagen und das wir ja
schon sehr praktisch wenn man diesen
termin dann erreichen könnte ja und was
ist mit den anderen nun die
linksfraktionen das ist natürlich keine
überraschung sie ist gegen dieses
sondervermögen gegen eine bessere
ausstattung der bundeswehr und sie hat
auch ein durchaus gutes argument denn es
ist ja so dass die bundeswehr von 33
milliarden vor ein paar jahren
aufgestockt wurde auf 50 milliarden etat
und auch mit diesen 50 milliarden sind
diese ganzen missstände zustande
gekommen dass eben munition fehlt das
viele panzer nicht fahren und
argumentiert die linke nicht ganz zu
unrecht geld alleine macht es nicht bei
der beschaffung der versicherte das geld
und wenn wir jetzt 100 milliarden geben
dann werden wir das wieder erwähnt
erleben und genau das ist natürlich eine
der gefahren amira mohammed ali
jedenfalls die fraktionschefin der
linksfraktion hat hier vor ihrer sitzung
noch einmal klar gemacht die linke wird
gegen dieses gesetz des sondervermögens
stimmen
ich habe ein jahr eine reihe von themen
mitgebracht ich möchte beginnen mit dem
thema sondervermögen für die bundeswehr
da hat es eine einigung gegeben heute
nacht und ich möchte es in aller
klarheit mal sagen die sondervermögen
ist einfach eine unverschämtheit ich
finde das unmöglich dass die
bundesregierung das von der union
tatsächlich durchwinken möchte eine
grundgesetzänderung
änderungen um aufrüstung möglich zu
machen
erst haben die vorherigen
bundesregierung eine schuldenbremse ins
grundgesetz geschrieben
wir haben noch als linke immer
kritisieren auch aus gutem grund denn
die folge davon haben wir gesehen
sozialabbau investitionsstau überhaupt
kein fortkommen beim ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien marode schulen ein
kaputtgespart ins gesundheitssystem und
so weiter und jetzt plötzlich
es gelte aber nicht für alle diese
notwendigen dingen 100 milliarden euro
sollen fürs militär ausgegeben werden an
der schuldenbremse vorbei also
vollkommen unabhängig von der frage wie
die finanzielle lage eigentlich aussehen
plötzlich ist das nicht mehr wichtig
wenn es uns militär geht
und außerdem auch völlig unabhängig von
der frage wie eigentlich die weltlage
aussieht denn die man hört würde es
überhaupt keine regelung geben wird
schuldenbremse entschuldigung dass sie
schon können sie wieder greift das ist
ein sondervermögen eben ausgesetzt wird
denn jetzt zum beispiel der krieg in der
ukraine endet oder wenn was wir alle
hoffen vielleicht demnächst der
weltfrieden über uns kommt auch dann
würde es weiter so sein dass nach
unserem grundgesetz dann weiter
aufgerüstet werden kann und das ist doch
einfach absoluter irrsinn wenn man
bedenkt dass bereits heute 50 milliarden
euro jahr für jahr in den
verteidigungsetat fließen kann man nur
feststellen
ein weiteres reinwerfen von immer mehr
steuergeldern in dieses schwarze loch
rüstungsetat ist einfach der falsche weg
es wird behauptet das sei notwendig
damit die bundeswehr endlich ihren
grundgesetzlichen auftrag erfüllen kann
nämlich das land zu verteidigen
ja der grund gesetzlicher auftrag ist
richtig und ja es wäre auch sinnvoll die
bundeswehr dafür aus zu starten aber es
ist überhaupt nicht erkennbar warum
jetzt dieses mehr geld diese aber und
abermilliarden irgendeinen beitrag dazu
leisten sollten denn ich frage ernsthaft
wo sind denn bisher die ganzen
milliarden geblieben 50 milliarden pro
jahr ich sage es noch einmal und ich
kann ihnen sagen wo die gesichert sind
ins portemonnaie der rüstungskonzerne
und in die beraterfirmen hier haben sich
einige gruppen los die taschen voll
gemacht und das soll jetzt immer
weitergehen wir sehen dass die
aktienkurse von rheinmetall onko bereits
durch die decke gehen und immer weiter
steigen ist einfach unverantwortlich
wir bräuchten dringend ein
sondervermögen für den ausbau der
schulen der infrastruktur für
krankenhäuser und natürlich auch für den
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien das
wäre eine richtig gute schlussfolgerung
wir bräuchten dringend mehr
unterstützung für bürgerinnen und bürger
in anbetracht der der inflation
anbetracht der enorm steigenden
lebenshaltungskosten aber nein dafür
gibt es kein sondervermögen darf wird
die bevölkerung wenn überhaupt mit ein
paar brosamen abgespeist und hier sagen
wir es linke ganz klar nein diesen
irrsinn machen wir nicht mit wir sind
gegen das sondervermögen bundeswehr
deren aufrüstung ist sie nicht die
richtige antwort und ich finde es
richtig und wichtig dass es im deutschen
bundestag wenigstens eine fraktion geht
nämlich die linke die sich hier gegen
diesen irrsinn stellt
wir haben 2 5 millionen kinder in
deutschland in armut nach wie vor
kindergrundsicherung ist versprochen
worden ist nicht gekommen immer noch
nicht ist auch nicht in aussicht dafür
ist kein geld da aber für rüstung das
geht nicht sagen wir in aller
deutlichkeit
ich komme zum nächsten thema zum krieg
in der er in der ukraine der
schreckliche krieg russlands in der
ukraine
auch der spitzt sich immer weiter zu
immer mehr menschen sterben die
zerstörung wird immer größer tausende
sind auf der flucht die lage ist nach
wie vor furchtbar und furchtbar ist eben
auch dass eine waffenruhe nicht in sicht
ist das liegt aber auch daran dass
diplomatische bemühungen überhaupt nicht
ausgereizt werden wie man es eigentlich
tun müsste und hier bleiben wir auch als
linke dabei das ist unsere erwartung
auch an die bundesregierung oder chance
und auch an die außenministerin dass sie
sich dafür stark macht dass sie mit
einem dramatischen mitteln endlich eine
waffenruhe erwirkt wird und das
möglichst schnell auch der ukrainische
präsident hat vollkommen zu recht gesagt
dass man ein ende des krieges nur durch
diplomatie erreichen kann und wenn ich
dann jetzt die deutsche außenministerin
kürzlich allen ernstes sagen höre sie
befürchtet es gebe in deutschland eine
kriegsmüdigkeit
dann muss ich sagen schockiert mich das
zutiefst also einmal bin ich der meinung
es ist vollkommen normal und richtig von
krieg müde zu sein wir müssen doch alle
wollen dass ein krieg möglichst schnell
endet und außerdem geht es hier vor
allem darum die bevölkerung irgendwie
zum durchhalten anzugehen eine
durchhalteparole ob der gestiegenen
kosten lebenshaltungskosten
energiekosten lebensmittelkosten und all
das und ich finde es unglaublich dass
die bundesregierung weiterhin konsequent
diese note ignoriert und eben eine
wirksame maßnahmen ergreift um dagegen
vorzugehen dafür zu sorgen dass das
leben für alle menschen bezahlbar ist
nein stattdessen werden solche
durchhalteparolen durchgestellt das geht
überhaupt nicht da erwarten wir als
linke von der bundesregierung wirklich
deutlich mehr es ist dringend notwendig
dass die eskalation im krieg in der
ukraine das oberste gebot ist und wir
erwarten hier dass die bundesregierung
sich entsprechend einsetzt
waffenlieferungen sind der falsche weg
ist bleibt dabei die bundesregierung und
ihren vorgängern vorgängerregierung
hatten sich selbst die regel gegeben
dass waffenlieferungen kriegsgebiete
nicht erfolgen dürfen das ist nach wie
vor richtig diese waffenlieferungen
drohen eine eskalation des krieges zu
befördern und das muss in jedem fall
vermieden werden deswegen sind wir
anderer position dann nach wie vor klar
waffen liefern an der ukraine sind der
falsche weg
amira mohammed ali die co
fraktionsvorsitzende
der linksfraktion bleibt noch die afg
die heute morgen überraschend ein
hintergrundgespräch absagte und dann
anschließend auch hier die
pressekonferenz auf der fraktionsebene
ich kann ihnen nicht genau sagen warum
das so ist jedenfalls scheint die afd
auch mit anderen dingen beschäftigt zu
sein sie hat ja bald parteitag
untersteht die macht und führungsfrage
an das ist aber nur eine mutmaßung ja
das soll es hier von der fraktionsebene
in berlin aus dem deutschen bundestag
gewesen sein ich bitte sie bleiben sie
dran jetzt geht es bei uns weiter mit
der tag und meinem kollegen bernd raase
die einigung beim sondervermögen
bundeswehr ist eines der themen heute
abend bei der tat